so what's it gonna be
Ant-Man
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. Marvel finally
dropped the full Ant-Man 3 Quantumania trailer
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs here
whole bunch going on so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos Remember the
movie is coming out in February we won't have to
wait that long for it to come out the song that's
actually playing on the trailer is Elton John's
Goodbye Yellow Brick Road because they're going
with the Wizard of Oz theme in Kang is meant to
be The Wizard of Oz the person who's stuck in
the Land of Oz which is the Quantum realm in this
case the basic idea of the movie is that his Honey
I Shrunk the Kids but with the quantum realm and
Ant-Man characters just because mostly Ant-Man
movies play on a lot of Comedy obviously very
dramatic too like Kane gets very serious during
this and I know lots of questions about what's
going on with Bill Murray too but the basic idea
I believe is that Kang is stuck in the quantum
realm and they have a version of his chronopolis
from the comics like his City that he uses to
control his aspect of the Kang Multiverse War
like he's trying to dominate The Kang Multiverse
War 2.0 after the events of the Loki series and
this version of Kang is a just using the quantum
realm to do that I'm sure that there are many
other versions of Kang out there across the
Multiverse that are doing the same thing they
also clarify a little bit about how the quantum
realm exists in relation to the rest of the MCU
proper no Multiverse the way Janet Van Dyne calls
it a completely separate Universe on a Quantum
scale like underneath our own 616 Marvel Universe
makes it sound like it's just one of the infinite
number of different universes in the Multiverse
instead of like a substrate that sort of reaches
to all different universes in the Multiverse
but the big reason why Kang would want to use
the quantum realm is because he needs the quantum
energy to power all this technology his control
of time and space like all of his Tech during the
Loki series was based on Quantum Tech that's why
the energy looked like the same energy signature
that the Avengers used when they were using
Quantum energy to travel through time and space
for their big time heist mission just starting
at the beginning of the trailer and working our
way through shot by shot I believe this is meant
to take place in relatively Real Time with the
other Marvel phase 4 Marvel Phase 5 movies but
this is meant to be the official beginning of
Marvel phase 5. there's a any confusion black
panther wakanda forever is the official ending of
Marvel phase 4 the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special is kind of like a special case that's
sort of like a tail end of Marvel phase four
so this is taking place after the events of black
panther wakanda Forever After the events of Thor
11 Thunder for instance everything is meant to be
going great in Scott Lang's life like his family
is doing amazing he's getting all this credit for
everything he did with the Avengers he's even got
a podcast about all of his Avengers stuff that
we learned about during Ms Marvel most of this
trailer is actually the trailer they showed off
at d23 with like a couple minor tweaks there are
a couple lines that I didn't see in this trailer
that were in the d23 trailer they pay off the joke
with him in the Baskin Robbins Baskin Robbins
always finds out suddenly they're treating him
like the employee of the century because of what
he did during Avengers end game he high-fives a
little kid who's got an Ant-Man backpack so he's
making money off the merch there's all these jokes
about how the Avengers don't get paid they kind
of did that during Falcon and Winter Soldier and
they've addressed it in a couple other series even
during She-Hulk the idea of merchandising all the
Avengers stuff and all the bootleg Avengers
merch so some of them have managed to turn
their superheroing into a profit without getting
super Shady about it love the old coffee shop
owner that confuses it for Spider-Man thank you
very much Spider-Man it also lets you know that
this late in Marvel Phase 5 people still know all
about Spider-Man even though they don't know that
he's Peter Parker because that's how the spell
worked like they just erased their knowledge
that he was Peter Parker not that Spider-Man
existed entirely so like all the Avengers still
remember fighting with Spider-Man during Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers endgame they just don't
remember that it was Peter Parker that was doing
it with them they kind of addressed that during
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness where Doctor
Strange references Spider-Man being this superhero
also in New York City and the stuff that they've
done together but didn't know that he was Peter
Parker this is where we get to more of the Honey I
Shrunk the Kids Vibe where the adult casting Lang
now because she's obviously grown older because
of the five-year time Jump they've recast Kathryn
Newton as the character she's created a distressed
Beacon that will help people contact them from
the quantum realm who need help but Kang winds up
using this again against them like Janet van dyne
gets really upset like wait a minute you have a
beacon going to the quantum realm no no you got
to turn that off right now we don't want to go
down there again because you remember Janet Van
Dyne was stuck down there for over 20 years she
lived in the quantum City that's how she continued
to survive she met all those people she worked
with them that's how the Bill Murray character
knows her and she probably knew all about what
was going on with Kang like we need to stay away
from there as much as possible there are a lot
of dangerous people down there so basically what
Kane does is he uses his technology to pull them
into the quantum realm and the Big Ideas that he
basically holds Cassie Lang captive and forces
Scott Lang to steal something from him that he
needs for his time travel platform to power all
of his technology so that he can fulfill his plans
to win the Kang Multiverse War that's why at the
end of the trailer he tells him do we have a deal
Ant-Man where he basically says I'll get you hope
back I'll get you more time because during a lot
of the trailer footage in the other extra d23
footage that isn't in this trailer he makes a
lot of time travel references just references
to time in general like saying we're both men
who have lost a lot of time you also notice the
Kang is wearing his full-on Kang the Conqueror
suit from the comics like this is meant to be the
full version of Kang the Conqueror now because
they said that we're going to see many versions of
Kang in the future Marvel projects this might not
be the version of Kang that we see in Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty that could be a completely different
one but regardless of what happens to this version
of Kang like if he becomes a much bigger villain I
just think it's cool that they're actually giving
us the real version of Kang the Conqueror because
the version during Loki was he who remains was
sort of a combination of that and his immortus
version of the character Kang at the end of his
timeline this is Kang in his prime we get the
Elton John Goodbye Yellow Brick Road song like
I said this is a big Wizard of Oz metaphor with
Kang being the wizard himself who is stuck in Oz
because he needs the technology for Ant-Man to
steal to power his time travel platform so that
he can conquer all the Multiverse really cool
transition here with the Marvel Studios logo on
top of the quantum realm as they're transitioning
into it and obviously this is meant to be a
much Fuller version of the quantum real much
more detailed than we've ever seen before we saw a
version of during Ant-Man and the wasp and we saw
a version of the quantum City in the background
but it was like really tiny like zoom in enhance
and you see the quantum City this time it's up
close it looks more like an actual City and when
Janet Van Dyne calls it an entire universe just
at the quantum level that's why you see so many
different types of alien looking creatures there
like they're not all the same type of being but
you also remember because it is the Quantum realm
you could enter or exit at any point in time and
space like it's connected to all of time and space
which is why it's so important for Kang although
Quantum energy powering is technology that helps
him control all of time all these other types of
beings that you see them meet are just beings
from other places inside this Quantum universe
so to speak they make it seem like a lot of them
are refugees like Janet Van Dyne was like she got
stuck in the quantum realm here on this particular
place they're probably stuck there as well so the
big idea here is that Janet Van Dyne kind of takes
the lead when they go down there because she lived
there for over 20 years and even though Hank Pym
is a genius they're Meant To Be The Fish Out of
Water this time we see Kang powering up some
of his time travel devices and when I made a
reference to chronopolis that's what it seems like
this place is like this is like a giant version of
his smaller time travel platform that you see
him on later like I said using this to control
all of time and space at a much much larger level
you can let me know in the comments if you think
that they're using this to set up a version of
Kang for Avengers 5 Kane Dynasty like it could
be the same Kang just because this seems like it's
so big it would be weird if they killed off this
version of Kang and that was the end of it the way
he comes off in the trailer too is that he's sort
of benevolent like he wants to help Scott Lang but
he's also being really evil at the same time like
yeah I've stolen your daughter I'm probably gonna
kill her unless you help me but they want you to
sympathize with him at least a little bit like you
understand why he's doing what he's doing it's the
same thing with the Thanos was right memes like
first he seems with this crazy villain but then
after Avengers end game you get all these Thanos
was right memes like oh no no he actually had some
good ideas there it'll be the same thing after
this comes out people be like Kang was right you
may have seen all the Ant-Man jokes too because he
got super huge for his other movie with Michael B
Jordan the Creed 3 movie so he looks ripped now
R.I.P Ant-Man Kang is definitely going to spank
him hard in this film he didn't actually get super
ripped for Ant-Man 3 like he's just in a regular
shape he got super ripped for a Creed 3 but I
still like the metaphor like Scott Lang has no
chance against him one of the other cool details
that you notice here too when you see all of his
troops lined up obviously this is very attack of
the Clones looking with all the clone troopers
they're all wearing the same looking suits the
Kang has on the same Kang the Conqueror type of
suit so I'm wondering if these are all just
other versions of Kang that are working for
him and they're using a very Council of Kangs
kind of twist like everybody you see walking
around in the suits is just another Kang sort of
like a Rick and Morty situation with the Citadel
of Ricks except make a Kang this is just his
regular time travel platform where he actually
controls everything from surprisingly his Kang
the Conqueror suit in the MCU looks very similar
to what a lot of the fan art looks like this is
just meant to be a regular bar populated by just
other random creatures beings that have come from
other play planets inside this Quantum realm where
it seems like Janet Van Dyne goes to meet people
that she knows and get more information get more
help and now talking about Bill Murray so a lot of
people wondering what's going on with him because
he looks human is he another actual human from
Earth or is he just humanoid looking all I really
know about his character is that I believe he's
playing a version of krylar who's a villain from
the comics like he's secretly a villain Bill
Murray said that he's playing a very bad guy
during the movie and he is an alien but in the
comics he has green skin the character actually
debuted in The Incredible Hulk number 156 and it
was inside the microverse which is the Quantum
realm they couldn't use the name microverse in
the MCU because I believe that Hasbro owns the
micronauts which owns the term microverse so they
just had to change the name and that's why it's
called the quantum realm instead of the microverse
that also kind of makes you think of the Rick and
Morty mini verse and teeny verse in the comics
krylar was another evil scientist just creating
really bad stuff even though Kang is meant to be
the main villain of the film there's also supposed
to be a version of Modok and I think that Bill
Murray might have something to do with that like
he might have turned Corey stoll's yellow jacket
into the version of MCU Modok that's the big rumor
is that like they show a version of Modok in the
d23 trailer this is what he looks like but this
looks like a face mask in underneath when it falls
off it might be Corey Stoll's face or version of
it like that Darren Cross version of Modok so they
might be trying to hijack Kang's technology but I
still think that Kang is meant to be the main
Villain Like You See Ant-Man here surrounded
by all of Kangs technology and then you see him
sending him to steal something from this other
area here we see a bunch of dangerous creatures
inside the quantum realm you see a really freaky
scene of Ant-Man running towards something but
there's a bunch of other versions of Ant-Man like
there's a giant man that just sort of unravels
there's another Ant-Man in front of him this is
probably just playing on the whole idea of the
time travel technology the metaphor with Kang
the Conqueror like it's the same Ant-Man but it's
a bunch of different versions of him from across
the timeline we also see casting Lang in the
purple Stinger suit she's had a couple different
versions of her character like she's been stature
and been more of a version of giant woman but but
in this version her power is a little bit closer
to the wasp's Powers she could basically do all
the same things that Janet Van Dyne and hope Van
Dyne can do and yes I totally think that they're
going to do a Young Avengers project and she'll
be on it at some point what are the lines of
dialogue that they don't include in this that was
in the d23 version of the trailer is he says have
I killed you because he knows who the Avengers
are but he's killed so many of them across the
timeline across different battles that he's had
that he forgets which is which like are you one
of the Avengers that I've killed before did we
just have a battle a little while ago I can't
remember there's been so many of them I've killed
you so many times just more time travel references
so like I said I think some of this is meant to
set up Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty in a big way but
I don't know if it'll be this version of Kang or
another version hopefully it won't just be this
version he'll wind up getting away or he'll wind
up accomplishing his goal at the end of the film
we've also seen a version of Kang the Conqueror
in the Loki season 2 trailer I've already done
a much bigger video about that from d23 in that
footage so we'll link that at the end of this I
think that that's going to be a separate version
of Kang because remember infinite versions of Kane
now released because of what happened at the end
of Loki season one this is coming out in February
Loki season 2 will come out till the spring or
the summer so that's why I say I think it might
be separate versions of Kang the Conqueror but
I do think that there'll be some Easter eggs
between the two of them if you spotted any other
big Easter eggs in the trailer footage that it
didn't talk about in the video or you have any
big other questions about the movie just post
them in the comments below and I'll add them to
my future bonus videos also doing more Ant-Man
3 videos as we get closer to the movie coming
out we get more footage there's a bunch of black
panther wakanda forever footage that also just
dropped I'll do a video for that soon in my new
house of the dragon season 2 video we'll post next
you can click here for that I'll update the link
as soon as I post it and click here for my Loki
season 2 trailer video with that other version
of Kang thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!